[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
happy
Monday everyone it's great to be back
for now
so I had an anniversary this weekend yes
it was the seventh anniversary of the
first time I saw Kim Kardashian's butt
in person
see that is me uh right there
I'm behind her and to the right and you
can clearly see my eyes were laser
focused
[Laughter]
on that thing
and that thing was so big it kind of
felt like it was staring back now this
happened in 2016 at the White House
Correspondents Dinner I haven't gone
since because how could I top that but
this weekend's version of the event also
reminded me why I haven't been back
either mainstream media sucks and it's
worse than a tux because the coverage
reminds us of exactly what it really is
about something I call ego affirming
care it's where members of the so-called
Free Press can inflate their self-esteem
like Chinese spy balloons and like every
award show it's artificially created as
a reminder that they matter it's where
they can Savor a shrimp cocktail along
with the smell of Joe Biden's lingering
farts
they smell like butterscotch
that's what happens when you Mainline
werthers
to say DC is Hollywood for ugly people
is unfair to ugly people at least ugly
folks hide their faces when they're not
on CNN so as usual the media puts a
staggering amount of energy to invite
people that make themselves look cool as
the Washington Post points out a good
guest can help validate the importance
of a news organization and the jockeying
for dinner guest starts as early as
January
so Britney skriner was a guest of CBS
you know it's a good thing we cut that
trade done for the Russian arms dealer
in time right because she brought the
weed
and guests needed to be really high to
laugh at most of those jokes
she sat with Gail King who was relieved
to not be the tallest lesbian in the
room
she's straight but as always it was
surreal to watch some of the worst
people in Washington rub shoulders with
some of the worst people in Hollywood
that Adams Family reboot looks pretty
good right huh
they've already cast lurch
[Laughter]
John Legend and Chrissy Teigen were also
there and like any good Royal Chrissy
had some helpful servants to carry the
train of her dress they should just be
thankful they'll never have to do that
for Eric swalwell
you know because he farts you know maybe
we should just kill that joke after a
while nobody remembers it yeah
so why were those two there well they
were guests of NBC news but better
question why are they there NBC must
really hate the press to inflict that
kind of torture on this group it's a
cute prank of course invite the most
insufferable insufferable Credence and
let them flaunt their superiority all
over you plus they smell
I don't know that but I thought I'd add
that now the night was also a chance for
reporters to get chummy with the world's
biggest dummy
it had to be stressful for Joe's
handlers whenever he's under the bright
lights they're afraid he'll walk toward
them
[Laughter]
although I wonder in a lot of ways does
this dinner sum up his first two years
in office where he talks for 10 minutes
takes zero questions and then cheerfully
walks away in a lot of ways this dinner
sums up my first two years in office
I'll talk for 10 minutes take zero
questions and cheerfully walk away the
difference here being he didn't fall off
the stage trying to fist bump Caster
Casper the Friendly Ghost
the most powerful man in the Free World
just bragged about his contempt for the
press and they all just sat there and
chuckled haha good one boss you keep
tossing us the rotting fish and we'll
keep clapping like train SEALS or how
about this wise crack I had a lot of
random Roger Sanders jokes ready
but Becky but Mickey Mouse beat the hell
out of me got there first Mickey Mouse
beat the hell out of him for what trying
to sniff his ears
no doubt a mouse could kick Biden's ass
at this point I wouldn't take Joe over
Tinkerbell but that line made zero sense
so maybe it does sum up his time as
president I think maybe the teleprompter
said Mickey Mouse beat him to it and Joe
screwed up the punch line you know he's
the first president to read at a third
grade level
it's too bad that people have to pretend
that President's jokes were funny which
he wouldn't have to do if Trump was
there you'd think at least one time he'd
get up and say I'm running for president
uh where where am I going where the hell
am I going I want to get out oh no over
there
yeah fine
and you and you know Joe's decrepit when
you're getting mocked by a 76 year old
but it's too bad Trump never went
because he would have killed and not in
the Hillary Clinton Way
oh
Washington Post reporter Matt viser won
the Aldo Beckman award for capturing the
spirit of job of Joe Biden and that's a
tough Spirit to capture since it flees
Joe's body when he flat lines five times
a week
the judges said my advisor stood out
among his competitors for work that went
beyond the humdrum of covering the
managed events of the presidency in the
White House visor captured the spirit of
Joe Biden particularly with stories
about the president's brother and how
his Catholic faith influenced his
strategic vision of the office the what
whca is pleased to give the Aldo Beckman
award to Matt viser so his Catholic
faith influenced his vision
for the office how exactly you know
defending abortion up until the kid can
do his timetables
so a reporter gets an award for kissing
the president's ass how's that for
speaking truth to power but there were a
few good reporters there right they were
easy to spot because they were all from
the same place and unlike the crowd they
weren't ugly look at these four hotties
propping yeah
yeah
these these four striking ladies
propping up a billboard for Gamblers
Anonymous
now you might be saying Greg you're
better looking than all of them why
didn't you go thank you you're right but
I couldn't because Saturday night is
Twister night at the orphanage
let's welcome
tonight's guests she recently had speed
bumps installed in her larynx is that
how you say it host of The True Crime
brought Fox True Crime podcast Emily
Campagna
he's the best thing to happen to
education since books professor and
author of the new book The sad truth
about happiness dad sad
born in Philly he actually comes to New
York to feel safe CEO of electric bike
Technologies Jason Crabb
and finally she just flew back from
Chicago and boy are her arms skinny
excuse contributor captive
so Emily I you know when you look at the
news side of fox there are some people
they have to go to these things right
they don't have they have to go because
it's about the news but there are some
people who don't have to go like you and
still you went why did you go what's
your problem because I was invited
oh you were I did yeah so so that means
you go to anything that you're invited
to
I mean I I
guess
I didn't um tell me about it what was it
like for you well unlike Chrissy Teigen
I
brought my own dress on the train I did
my own hair and makeup you know I'm I'm
a normal human I carried it myself my
boyfriend zipped me up in the back and
then I I went to the dinner I hate the
part about the boyfriend I will say that
um you know hearing for example like
President Biden's quote like he said
this sums it up I agree is Scott
Jennings from CNN said you know he's
he's not laughing with you press core
he's laughing at you and the only
difference between that quote
um and the the truth like the full truth
would be summing up his two years of
presidency by lighting a match dropping
it and watching away because absolutely
there's been zero transparency and zero
engagement on a fundamental and real
level with a press Corps in addition to
figuratively burning this country to the
ground and for that guy to win an award
about his Catholic faith to your point
about the abortion and this is someone
who again a self-professed Catholic who
denies his grandchild yeah who has put
avenues for tripwires in Catholic
churches around the country under his
watch we know the f FBI director says oh
I'm a gassed quote at it I'm appalled I
didn't know it was happening but that's
Biden's America so this presidency is a
dumpster fire as was I guess his speech
because it lacked the real truth which
is that he only holds disdain for
everyone in that room myself included
but I had a good time Greg yes I
wouldn't right now the Secret Service is
wondering how did she get that close to
Biden
Professor congratulates on the new book
what is the secret to happiness before I
ask you about this thing do you have a
uh well I mean there's many but one find
the right spouse find the right job I'm
over too you're not kidding for two
I'm joking she doesn't watch everything
in moderation well there you go live
life as though it's a playground always
be smiling don't take yourself seriously
live without regret there's a whole
bunch of good stuff in there by the way
I have a bone to pick with you what your
book is being released on the same day
as mine I consider that a form of
anti-semitism
you know he's right do you have the
equivalent of this kind of
self-congratulation in academic circles
I you do yeah and I try to avoid it like
the plague Groucho Marx famously said
right I don't want to belong to a club
that would have me as a member yeah and
these guys are doing the exact opposite
please choose me please have me I
despise that kind of attitude I mean to
a fault I usually reject invitations to
go to these self-congratulatory things
in Academia so that was a slam at you no
it wasn't no
can I briefly mention a thing about uh
the train I think it's called the of
Chrissy so and you I know that you love
Evolution psychology the peacock has a
big tail because it serves as an honest
signal and a costly signal it has to be
wasteful in order for it to be
right discriminating right
discriminatory well she's doing exactly
that I mean literally there's a tale
behind her that shows look how wealthy I
must be to be able to engage in this
kind of wasteful consumption you know
and she could have saved a lot she could
just leave any bathroom stall and do the
same thing
that's when I leave a tray a train
that's for sure all right
sorry Jason did you learn do you what
what's your overall take from something
like this in yours because you're
outside the media I think out of all of
us here you're probably the furthest
from it yeah I am the least famous
person nobody knows who I am yeah we
like to keep it that way yeah and this
show will help that we'll see what
happens you know I love it
um this is like the Hunger Games for the
corrupt I mean talk about cronyism yeah
like if they're you know like we need
any more evidence that that these people
are making back room deals and
everybody's you know so familiar yeah
well they cut that they it's that thing
where like hey it's all you realize it's
all in so-called part of a game because
everybody's chummy after they try to
destroy each other yeah it's like some
weird like family reunion where they're
pretend they're not related but they're
all like distant cousins yeah exactly
and they're you know getting drunk
smoking weed in the shed and then
plotting to steal Granny's jewelry yes
is that all right yeah that's kind of
whatever all over the place yeah I know
but no it's listen this whole event is
like the American people are tired and
it's like they're all so full
can't take it anymore yeah they are
right am I famous now yeah yeah you
destroyed yourself cat how was your how
was your Chicago live show it was so
much fun was it what happened so many
fun you didn't get mugged or murdered no
I didn't I was hoping for the latter
yeah I thought that we would have such a
huge show we really need the ratings
yeah you were murdered yeah because it's
been kind of a rough week if I was
murdered would you just do one segment
on it so we talked about this we talked
about this the e-block or the final
thoughts cat's dead rip no but you know
what I the five said they would let me
do a one more thing okay but it would be
towards the end when we do the toss to
Brett so you might get 15 seconds all
right yeah well I yeah I had a great
time it was awesome I'm in DC on
Saturday if everybody wants to get
tickets at the realcatiff.com see I
throw my own events yes
uh and you went to this last year didn't
you yeah and I'm glad I did uh it was a
good experience to have it was a lot of
work to like get ready and all that and
you know Chrissy Teigen I don't I think
it's fine to be super rich what bothers
me about her is she also wants so
desperately to be relatable uh I
remember a few I think it was a few
years ago she tweeted what's the most
expensive thing that you ate that you
didn't like she's like one time I
accidentally ordered a 13 000 bottle of
wine yeah and people were not finding
that as relatable as she thought that it
was you'd be like oh I'd be in financial
ruin if I did that yeah um
if I if I had that kind of money for
people to like hold my dress I'd be like
I'm rich you just own it you know
and I but I don't right I bet I could
get some old men to do it for free all
right
there's a few I could actually probably
sell tickets to it yes uh but that's the
things pretending they're just like us
they're not just like us and that's fine
just kind of own it and it wouldn't be
so weird I accidentally ate a panda oh
yes no endangered Panda I was at a zoo
in China and I had no I thought you'd go
in you just kill it you eat it like it
was one of those hunt hunting
restaurants and you just Grill it I had
no idea
no way yeah anyway dad's like why are
you listening to him he's a liar hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else